[MUSIC]
I'm Jonathan Burke,
the AP Germany professor of finance at
the Graduate School of Business
at Stanford University.
>> And I'm Jules Van Vince Bergen,
the Nippon life professor in finance at
the Wharton School at
the University of Pennsylvania.
Join us on a journey as we
explore the science and
strategy of better decision making.
>> Today, we will consider
an important business decision.
The decision about whether
to buy a good business.
Whether you're a sole proprietor, think
of buying an established small business,
well, conglomerate concerning
the decision to buy up a new brand or
starting a new division,
the same question needs to be answered.
What is a good business to buy?
>> To make this decision concrete, let's
consider a business purchasing decision
most of us make,
buying stock in a public company.
How do you put together
a good stock portfolio?
Which stocks are good buys and
which ones are not?
>> So as usual, last week, I was
talking to one of my golf buddies and
he was telling me what
a great stock picker he is.
He's never ever told me about any
bad investments he's made but
he always tells me about
the great investments he makes.
The thing about this guy is his
investment strategy is incredibly simple.
He tries out products, if he likes
the products, he buys the stock.
And the question is, does that make sense?
Is his investment strategy a strategy
that's going to make you a lot of money?
>> Well, Jonathan,
your buddy's argument sounds pretty
convincing if we hold all else equal.
All else equal, a firm that makes good
products is certainly a better investment
than a firm that makes bad products.
But can we hold all else equal?
And as we've now seen several times,
the answer to that question is usually no.
We have to think this through carefully.
>> And the thing that is holding all
else equal is he's not worrying about
the price.
So holding all else equal if I have two
investments and they cost the same,
I would much rather invest for
the good company than a bad company.
But as we discussed last time,
you can never hold all else equal.
If the company is a particularly good
company, it's going to have a high price.
So really what you're interested in
is not whether the company is good or
bad but whether or not the price of the
company is a good price or a bad price.
>> Yes, because overpaying for a good
company is a bad investment strategy,
whereas underpaying for a bad company will
make you a lot of money going forward.
So it's not just about
what you're getting, but
also what you're paying for it.
>> And so the real question is not
whether the company is good or bad, but
what price you're paying for the company?
And I'd like to make the argument that for
non professional, it's going to be very
rare or next to impossible to find
investments whose prices are attractive.
Or another way of saying this,
is it's going to be really hard for
such a person to find good
deals in the stock market.
>> What it's all about is about
competition and whether or not you have
a competitive advantage that you can
exploit when you're picking stocks.
Because if there's a good deal but
everybody already knows about it,
then everybody will want to invest in
it and everybody will put in by orders.
There going to be too many buyers and
not enough sellers.
And so the price will go up and
the investment opportunity will disappear.
And so the only way in which you can
make money investing in good companies
between quotation marks is if
you arrive at the party early,
meaning you find out that the products
that the company makes are better than
what people thought up until that point.
And so if you're the first one to figure
that out and you get into that stock
early, there may still be a possibility
for you to make some extra returns.
But if you're arriving at the party at
exactly the same time as everybody else,
then obviously,
you're not going to be making extra money.
>> And it's not easy to
arrive at that party early.
And the reason is,
there are a lot of people who devote their
entire lives to looking for good parties.
And it's unlikely that individually
investors will have the time or
the resources to do a better job than
the people whose career is built
on trying to arrive at the party early.
It's like a sports fan stepping
onto a football field and
thinking they can out play Tom Brady.
It's just not a very likely event.
>> Indeed, and so I mean,
it's not that there are no good and
bad investment decisions in the market.
I think that the main thing is,
can average investors tell them apart?
Because to be able to tell them apart,
you need to have something
that other people don't have.
That's exactly that competitive advantage
point and, of course, by definition,
the average investor doesn't have
a competitive advantage compared to
everybody else.
>> Jules,
when I teach this concept in class,
I always tell an old joke which finance
professors have told for decades.
The joke goes like this.
A finance professor and his student
are walking down the street, and
they see $100 bill lying on the ground.
And then the student reaches down
to pick the $100 bill up, and
the professor says to the student,
don't bother.
If that really was $100 bill,
it will be taken already.
And then I add to this joke an addendum,
and
the addendum I add is,
I look at my students and I say to them,
how many of you have actually
found a $100 bill on the ground?
And nobody raised their hand.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Nobody raises their hand.
And the ensuing silence is exactly
the point, which is A, if there is $100
bill that's lying on the ground,
it's going to be picked up very quickly so
the likelihood of you
finding it is very low.
And B, if you have $100 bill in your
pocket, you're going to look after
it very carefully and so
you're very unlikely to drop it.
>> So, well, one thing that you
can add to that though, and
that that really introduces that idea of
competition into this joke is that it
depends a bit on how busy the street is.
If the street is completely
full of people, that of
course the probability that that $100 bill
will stay lying there is incredibly low.
If the street is abandoned and
nobody's there,
that of course the $100 bill
might lie there for a bit longer.
Although of course, once it would become
known that $100 bills are lying around on
the street all the time, my prediction is
that we'll get really busy really soon.
>> And also, your competitive advantage.
If you happen to live on a street that's
a very quiet street and somebody dropped
$100 bill, your likelihood of picking it
up is much higher than an average person.
>> Yes, absolutely.
Another addendum to this example,
which I really liked to make in class is
this idea that, suppose that
there's this building out there.
And you are convinced that it's
full of $100 bills and actually,
you talk to a lot of people.
And a lot of people say there are $100
bills lying in this building all
over the place and you think to yourself,
I should be going to this building because
why on earth is nobody going there
to pick up all these $100 bills?
You get so overconfident, you go into the
building, start picking up the one hundred
dollar bills,
the building collapses and you're dead.
And so in the end, there was a reason
why people were actually not going into
that building to pick up those bills.
It was just that you are not realizing
what the rest of the market knew that you
didn't know.
And you should have thought it
through better and think why is it?
Can I understand why the rest of the
market is not going into that building to
pick up those $100 bills?
>> It's another all else equal mistake,
right?
If I know there's a really good deal
out there, then all else equal,
I should take advantage of the deal.
But everything is not all else equal.
The fact that nobody else is taking
advantage of the deal tells me that there
must be something else going on.
It's too easy.
>> Indeed, so, Johnson, how does
information get into prices, right?
So suppose that The price of a stock
is lower than it should be and
therefore it is a good buying opportunity.
So I just said it was a given quality for
a firm that the price of the stock is not
reflecting that call that
means the price is too low, so
how is that price going to take quality?
>> Well I mean, first of all,
everybody is going to want that deal.
Everybody wants a good deal.
So, people are going to
start buying that stock.
At the same time somebody
has to sell that stock.
If it is a good deal to buy,
it is a bad deal to sell.
So that means not only am I getting a good
deal, somebody else is getting a bad deal.
And I would argue that that's
not going to last very long.
They're very quickly the people selling
are going to say wait a minute I don't
want to sell it for such a low price.
And the people buying are going to
queue up to buy at that low price and
very quickly the price will start rising.
And will rising until the point
where it's no longer a good deal.
In deed, and the same thing
of course holds when we tick
the other scenario where
the price is too high and
then the price will be bid
down through the same process.
To arrive at the right level of the price.
And really the only way you can get
a good deal in market is you have to
be the first person who arrives.
And you don't have to buy and you buy
a limited amount and then you can make
money, and there are people that do that
but they need a lot of resources and
a lot of skill to find those special
deals that nobody else sees.
So the key thing then is to determine
whether or not the price is higher or
lower than where it should be.
And so the question then is,
how do you measure the should be?
And so therefore often what we talk about
is what's called price multiples which
are relative measures of valuation.
And so for different firms she can take
the ratio of the price per share to
the earnings per share of the company.
Or you can take the ratio of the price
per share of the company to what's called
the book value of equity.
Which is a measure per share of the
replacement value of the plant property
equipment and all the capital that
the firm uses to produce its products.
And some savvy investors understand
the all else equal argument and
understand that it's
the relative price that matters.
They almost always just talk in terms
of multiples rather than in price.
So let's go and talk to Cliff Asness
because Cliff Asness is an expert in
finding good deals and markets and he has
a particular approach to go about this.
He's been very successful at it.
So let's see what he
has to say about this.
>> Okay, well, welcome to the show.
We're very honored to have you.
For people who don't know Cliff Asness
is manager and co founder of
AQR Capital Management one of
the largest asset managers in the world.
And I would say not only that universally
regarded as one of the most successful
asset managers in modern history and
it's really an honor to have you here.
>> Thank you Jonathan I think
that's a gross exaggeration but
I enjoy gross exaggeration so.
>> Welcome we're very happy to have you.
>> Certainly our speakers the objective
in this particular episode is to
talk about what has commonly
become known as efficient markets.
The idea that a good
stock is not a good buy.
It's a cheap stock, that's a good buy.
So with that in mind,
I have two questions for you,
one question is a very general question.
How hard is it to find
good deals in the market?
But I'm going to make that very specific,
because this morning large brush my teeth
and I was thinking about this interview.
I was thinking about
that very specifically.
Lots and lots of architects go and
try to do what you do.
And the thing is, and we know academics
are very smart, but the thing is,
not all of them succeed.
What is it, that allows some people to
succeed and other people not to succeed?
>> Well, first of all,
it's nice to know in the era of Zoom,
you're still brushing your teeth.
I'm not sure all of us are doing that.
I'm going to give you
kind of a weird answer.
Obviously, some people can translate the
theoretical to the practical better and
the real world trading costs and
size you can run and and
judgments about whether something is real
or whether it's a data mined artifact.
Those all do very but
I'm going to give you an answer that
maybe would be a little surprising.
The capacity to withstand pain and
the capacity to explain
when things are not working,
why they're not working.
You have to be good at
what you do long term.
If you could stick with it and convince
others to stick with it I think you'd at
least have a reasonably
good investment product.
Those two things that are often
an afterthought, you being able to
tolerate it and don't think you're
not your worst client on occasion.
And being able explain it to others,
in a real world investing strategies
even if you're very good,
work a little more than they don't.
They don't work all the time.
People talk about stocks for the long run.
I'm in geek speak.
And I'm sure your students
are familiar with these things.
The stock market's like a point for
Sharpe ratio.
Go simulate that in Excel.
It's excruciatingly hard
to stick with at times.
And if anything, my answer to that
question is probably pretty different than
it would have been 20 years ago.
I think I appreciate that side
of it both for ourselves and for
clients how tough it is to
stick with a strategy, for
truly everyone talks about the long term
actually being long term is a superpower.
And in investing if you can
do it it is very hard to do.
>> That's a very surprising answer Cliff
because we spend a lot of time also in our
classroom and in our research thinking
about how to best design the strategy.
But what you're saying is that what is
really an important skill is to convince
both yourself as well as your clients
to stick with the ideas that you had.
And so the ability to withstand adversity
apparently is the most important skill.
Now we know that that's
generally true in life, but
apparently that is true here in
the investment world as well.
>> So tell when you're on the golf course.
You always got your body telling you
how much money he's made in the stock
market, right?
Let's assume they're telling the truth.
How do they do this without
the resources of AQR and
you're in all the intelligence of all
the employees you have and all of that?
>> I think when it comes to people who
are talking to their friends on the golf
course, I don't golf so
I'm trying to come up with someplace else.
I do go to cocktail parties,
occasionally back [INAUDIBLE] parties.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You get a lot of people talking about
the stock or even the market.
I don't think the market
is very easy to time and
you hear a lot of opinions about that.
Jonathan you said something important.
You said let's assume what
they're telling you it's true,
a I don't always assume that but for
the sake of your argument I will.
But what I won't assume is that
the people who lose terribly are as
anxious to tell their golf course stories.
>> Yeah, you're so right about that,
people rarely tell me how poorly
they've done on their stock picks.
I mean, this is also one of
the reasons for why we study,
when we study investment managers,
that when returns are self reported,
of course the funds that did
well are much more likely
to report the results than
the funds that didn't do so well.
>> So by the way this is not different
than fear of missing out FOMO on Facebook.
They tell us as a epidemic of depressed
people because everyone thinks
that other people's lives
are better than theirs.
because they're looking at their
Facebook or their Instagram and
all the fun they're having.
You don't hear about people's problems
on Facebook as exceptions to that of
course but
as a rule they're positive posts.
You don't see people at cocktail parties
going, man, I suck at stock picking.
Let me tell you about the, I made all
this money but I lost it all on these.
Again, there are exceptions.
I would listen to that person at
the cocktail party, they'd be kind of fun.
The honest person who's telling you that,
but that's not the rule.
So you do have to be very careful
of the financial version of FOMO.
Where your people are cherry
picking their winners,
even if they're not lying about them and
who speaks up is being cherry picked.
So I will call myself a cynic that
the individual doing this casually
can add a whole lot of value, certainly,
at the concentrated picking
of individual security level.
But I made a big concession to my
efficient market roots that I think there
are some people who clearly can.
>> When you think about we all have a golf
buddy or somebody like a golf buddy,
telling us what a genius they are.
One of the things that you notice
when people tell you about their
investment strategy in a social
environment is more often than not,
the investment strategy is so
simple, it is so clear to do.
And I always think to myself,
when these people tell me the strategy,
what makes them think that nobody else
has thought of such a simple strategy?
>> And also the question of, who is on
the other side of that trade, right?
I mean, this famous saying,
if you don't know who the sucker is,
it is probably you.
>> Yeah.
>> Jonathan,
I think you're thinking the same way.
But I would sum it up as they
leave price out of their strategy.
Often, their strategy is about what
they think is going to be a big thing.
Back in 99-2000 during the first
wave of kind of tech stock mania,
people would say things like, well,
the Internet's going to change the world.
And I think that was fairly
obviously true at the time.
The notion, all right,
should you be paying an infinite
multiple for drkoop.com?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
>> He was the Surgeon General,
who then launched the.com at the time.
There were many other examples.
The NASDAQ as a whole,
NASDAQ 100 was selling for
about 100 price to earnings multiples.
So the question, aside from trading,
trading is a whole different world.
If you're trying to predict what happens
tomorrow or even the next few months or
even even the next year, that's a lot.
Warren Buffett always talks about
a voting versus a weighing machine.
That is a voting machine.
If other people decide to
jump on the bandwagon,
a good trader doesn't necessarily
need to have a big grasp of price.
I'm a little cynical.
There are great natural traders who
can just feel the market also, but
I don't dismiss the possibility.
But if you're going to hold
something as an investor for
a decent length of time, there are really
basically two things that go into it.
The quality and can be multi dimensional
quality of how well they execute,
how fast they can grow,
what markets they're in, and
what price you're paying to begin with.
Let me tell you a story.
This is from the tech bubble, 99-2000.
I remember speaking to an audience and
the audience was very cynical.
I'm doing my value has never looked
more ridiculously stretched and
there are people there somebody
raised their favorite stock.
I forget which one it was but I've said
it was Cisco, the networking stock for
at least ten years, so I'm going to
stick with that though it may be a lie.
And I asked them, all right, basically,
this question, if you're going to
have to hold Cisco not for a month but
for 10, 20 years, you love it.
I get it, you love it and we disagree,
at what price would you get out?
And I was trying to induce them to answer
the question that we're groping around.
And the answer, I still love the answer.
Thank God,
I don't remember who it was because
it would be very mean of me if I did.
But the answer the person
gave me at the event was,
if it was selling for X, well,
if it dropped to half x, I'd be out.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They want the opposite way.
>> And perfect.
>> Again, they might have misunderstood.
I really did try to preface it
with this as a long term hold.
So basically saying, if I could buy this
for the next 20 years at half the price,
they were giving me a momentum
answer to a value question.
>> What I like about that analogy is,
it not only illustrates that professionals
can make all else equal mistakes,
but it's another example of where it
is difficult to stick by your guns.
That the earlier point you make that
a part of the skill of a professional is
somebody is willing to
stick with their strategy.
>> So earlier, you made a remark which
I found very interesting which was in
the golf course the person was willing to
discuss their mistakes would actually be
somebody that you would
be willing to listen to.
And you also seem very willing and open to
discuss the things that have gone poorly.
Why do you think this is so
difficult for most people to do?
>> Well, for one thing,
I just think most people haven't
thought through the strategy.
I think the world respects,
I'll be honest.
It's self-serving of me.
I think being open and
honest about these things.
The world respects it, not that I'm
always respected, don't always work.
[LAUGH] It doesn't work each time and
don't work with each person, but I think
on average, people do sense who's bs-ing
them and who's giving them the truth.
I do think I have gotten
better at it over my career.
It's kind of like all
the people do sports analytics.
Talk about how coaches who've been
successful over the long term
are actually better coaches.
Not because they've learned
what play works, but
because they're more steadfast in
doing the play they believe will work
even if it's going to get them yelled at,
if it doesn't.
So you do improve upon this.
But I think most people, they don't quite
get that if they leave with all the things
they've done wrong,
they can still impress people.
They can still have people think
they know what they're doing.
And this doesn't work for everyone.
If you're genuinely bad at what you're
doing and you're a bit of a boob,
leading with seven errors and
then never following it up with
substance is really not a good strategy.
So it does come down and
maybe I'm over endowed with this with
a certain level of self confidence.
Admitting your mistakes requires
self confidence because you have
to have faith that people will
make a judgment on the totality.
Not on the few things you told
them that you were stupid about.
So if I gave a life lesson, I've talked
to my kids about this, that is one.
I don't have a lot of great life lessons,
but that is certainly one.
That if you're down
the middle about yourself and
no one's perfectly down the middle.
We're all a little biased our own story.
But if you're down in the middle as you
can be, have some faith in other people.
I think it would work out for
many more people better than they think,
not just me.
I might have lucked into
the strategy over time.
>> I love that.
>> I think actually,
there's an extension to this,
which is not only do you
admit your mistakes, but
you learn from your mistakes,
I genuinely mean learn from your mistakes.
I don't mean, I made a mistake and
I repeat the same mistake again.
I really think to myself,
what caused me to make that mistake and
how could I not do that again?
I think it's a very difficult thing
to do and I think human beings really
I struggle with it,
I think the sippy future podcast for
business decision makers,
this is something we should focus on.
Why is it so hard to admit that
you've made a mistake and act on it?
>> Of course you're exactly right.
That is the second half,
admitting you made a mistake is lovely.
And it's it makes for
a very cathartic conversation.
But if you learn zero from that mistake,
admitting it doesn't actually help.
The second part is pretty important too.
So you're right I think they
often go hand in glove.
I think that person and not just me by any
means, but the person who can admit to
a mistake, almost by definition is at
least halfway down the road to asking,
why they made a mistake and
why they might not going forward?
I mean, it's kind of odd to imagine
someone admitting to a litany of mistakes,
and then saying, well, what are you
going to do to prevent that going forward
and have them, if you have this
conversation with someone,
they've made a couple of errors
even the life's been good.
And you go, well, what do you learn
from those errors, and they go, nothing.
[LAUGH] That will be odd.
I'm talking about ex ante errors,
not ex post errors, and
that's another one of the huge problems,
right?
I think ex ante,
we launched too aggressively.
In 1998, at AQR ex post,
we got one of the most
savage value drawdowns again
the next three years was wonderful.
So I'll always throw that in the marketing
at Has to go on, but that was ex post.
But I do think we made an ex ante mistake,
there is also if I can be
a little crass about it.
And someone at AQR is
going to yell at me for this.
Our legal world has people terrified to
say the words I made a mistake ever and
they're doing their jobs and
they're wonderful people,
at least the ones that are firm I actually
like our legal and compliance people.
But they never,
I scare them when I say things yeah,
I think we got that one wrong.
And they're, I can't say that I'm, does
anyone think we get everything, right?
Is there anyone on earth who thinks that,
my mother didn't think that, and
she was biassed towards me.
So I think that part of our culture, and
it doesn't mean it's a net negative.
There are a lot of legal protections we
have, and it does protect the world from
some things, but that part of the culture
also pushes any corporate Executive.
Away from the words yeah we were
wrong about that, one area bad.
>> So yeah, one of the reasons why we
decided to do the podcast to begin
with is because people make
mistakes all the time and
it is very difficult to learn from them.
And so
you really need to talk them through, and
see the commonalities in the mistakes
that people are making so thank you so
much Cliff for spending the time with us,
it's been really great and
it's been a lot of fun to
>> Now it has been fun thank
you guys Guys.
>> Thanks everybody for listening
we hope you enjoyed the podcast and
the interview with Cliff Asness
we learned a lot from him.
Certainly what he explained was that
not putting price into the equation
is going to make you make a mistake I
think that came through very clearly.
But I was surprised with the fact that the
most important investment management skill
was to stick with it and
to stick through it.
I hadn't expected that to be the answer to
the question what is the skill in shortest
supply.
So now next time we're going to
apply the same all else equal logic
to money management.
So, should you put your money
with the best manager and
best managers say a five star
rating manager by Morningstar?
If you put your money with that manager,
are you going to get high returns
going forward, yes or no?
That is what we are exploring next time.
And the guest we have for
that is Pete Berger, who is CEO of
the Fortress Investment Group, one of
the largest global investment managers.
>> Thanks for
listening to all else equal podcast.
Please leave us a review
at Apple podcasts,
we love to hear from our listeners.
And be sure to catch our next
episode by subscribing or
following our show wherever
you listen to your podcasts.
For more information and episodes visit,
all else equal podcast.com
Follow us on LinkedIn.
The All else equal podcast
is a joint venture of
Stanford University's Graduate School
of Business, and the Wharton School
at the University of Pennsylvania Yeah,
and he's produced a podium podcast.
[MUSIC]